Elden Ring's DLC has been essentially
confirmed data mines from sakiro dubi
and others have identified new game
files from the 1.07 patch that almost
necessarily guaranteed DLC even more
there is indication that this DLC will
feature the coliseums in some way likely
for PvP Arenas similar to what we got in
previous Souls games we don't know when
we'll get more concrete news from
fromsoft or what else the DLC might
bring so in the meantime we should
prepare for the eventual Announcement by
analyzing what we got being a lorehead I
want to discuss the potential lore of
the DLC now I don't want to just posit
aimless speculation about a possible
Nikola blood dream or something like
that but instead I want to explore what
tangible lore already exists around the
coliseums and see how this could maybe
tie into what can be found in the leaks
the details of the leaks have already
been covered well by channels like
zeostorm check him out for a more
thorough coverage so here I want to
focus on the lore connection but before
we get to that a word on this video
spawns nordvpn all this talk about leaks
and data dumps should remind us that
privacy on the Internet is a difficult
game to play fortunately for users like
us there are products to help keep our
data internet usage and gaming traffic
Safe products like our sponsor the
artisanal translucent VPN service
nordvpn right now Nord is offering a
truly exclusive deal at nordvpn.com mad
Luigi follow this link in the
description to get a huge discount on a
two-year plan plus four additional
months free that's right free who
doesn't like free I sure like free DLC
data mining info and with nord's 30-day
money-back guarantee you can try it out
risk-free if you follow the link and
sign up you'll also get access to nord's
new security feature resourcefully
called threat protection which will help
keep you safe from malware and malicious
sites something you may run into if
you're not careful online for instance
while downloading tools to let you see
inside the coliseums like I do in this
video not saying you should but just
saying be safe in any case visit
nordvpn.com mad Luigi to get this Luigi
certified hot deal
the most straightforward point of lore
we should look to in game is the
frustrated Spirit which can be found
outside of lim grave Coliseum it says
all I wanted was to fight to fight as a
warrior to the last so why why oh
guidance of Grace will this door not
open maybe this spirit is a stand-in for
us players who desperately want the
guidance of Grace to point towards the
Coliseum and let us get in there for
some PVP fights as Sakura doobie points
out in one of their older videos we can
find the ritual Shield Talisman outside
of the coliseum in Langdale it reads A
Talisman pattern after Shields used in
ritual combat held to honor the ER tree
raises defense when HP is at maximum the
practice had died out by the age of King
consort radagon but remains of the
Arenas were ritual combat took place can
still be found in every land finding
this outside of a potentially PVP arena
is likely no coincidence this might mean
that our fights are going to fit lore
wise into the story of Eldon ring as
being that ritual combat held to honor
the archery or perhaps there will
finally be some form of covenants or
teams we may get some support for this
idea and the fact that ranking up text
has been found in the game for a while
as evidenced by one of Sakira dube's
tweets if we do get new teams to fight
for some could fight for the Earth tree
and some could fight for other entities
like the Knox and underground cities or
the felgod or other outer Gods the fact
that the Talisman notes these fights
were held long ago before the age of
radagon could mean that we go to the
Past for the DLC or it could just
situate these fights as continuing an
already established practice but going
back to PVP covenants and teams for a
second let's look at the coliseum in
caled outside of this Amphitheater is
the great jar one of the most imposing
figures in the game size wise we don't
get reference about this great jar from
any other jars but Alexander and jar
Baron do speak of becoming great
warriors and battling worthy foes which
sounds like honorable dueling and what
we do at this Coliseum is nothing but
fight a series of duels obviously pvps
especially considering that the NPC's
weak fight are made from builds of other
players who have beat the gauntlet
Sakira dubi has a tweet that suggests
there may be some Gauntlet form in the
Arenas too which would be a pretty
height new addition in my eyes once we
defeat the great jar Champions we
receive the great jars Arsenal Talisman
which increases equip load it reads a
charm that resembles a great jar
overflowing with Weaponry vastly boosts
maximum equipment load the great jar
grants this Talisman to their Warriors
carry as much as you can grow big and
strong the Talisman designs shows and
mentions a host of weapons and a lot of
PV peers will have multiple weapons that
they'll switch in and out from during a
fight if you haven't seen some of the
PVP streamers navigate the weapons menu
during an invasion all I can say is
you're missing out another note here is
that the gray jar grants this Talisman
to their Warriors this entails a set of
Warriors that are the great jars going
off what I said before this could mean
that the great jar is one of the
covenants or teams to fight for in the
arena given the themes of the other jars
we see and the Very obvious placement of
the great jar in front of the Coliseum
this seems pretty likely to me and if
there ends up not being any
implementation of covenants I still
think that the great jar will be
connected in some way its placement is
just two in your face for it to not be
related somehow if we head over to the
Lim grave Colosseum we get another
peculiar encounter in game we have there
to pick up the Duelists for old finger
and the small red Effigy multiplayer
items that unfortunately don't give much
lore the fingertails of bronze
adornments and the Effigy says basically
nothing however there is more here is
where we get invaded by recusent
Enriquez and where we can invade Old
Knight is fun now henrikus or however he
pronounce his name I don't have too much
info for with regard to PVP connections
he drops the hammer Talisman which notes
that Tamers are highly effective against
Shield bearing foes so much so that they
are known as night Killers this could be
a small PVP reference in the sense that
we go up against other knights in PvP
but we get something a little bit more
substantial from the old night we invade
isvan on our first mission from the
volcano Manor he Bears the Scaled Armor
which reads the corroded metal is
reinforced with rock hard scales making
it highly effective against non-physical
attacks Estevan is one of a few wise and
tarnished who survived to this day he
wields a dismounter with a gravitas Ash
of war the sword is a curved Greatsword
wielded by the brawning sell swords of
Kaiden and the ash of war is a skill
originating from the alabaster Lords
with everything going on here from
negation armor to a varied weapon and
Ash of War I think this just might be
highlighting build variety especially
the kind we see in PvP it shows how an
old tarnished was only able to make it
through the ages with a good build
emphasizing the need for a similar one
when we enter the Arenas istmon can also
be summoned to fight the demi-human
chief Duo they drop the sewing needle
and the tailoring tools which giving us
the ability to alter how our armor looks
may be a connection to Fashion Souls an
incredibly important part of PVP and
online interaction arguably the most
important part finally I want to mention
the Duelists and their armor one last
tie-in to the possibility of going back
in time or at least just seeing the
coliseums in a functioning State we can
find some Duelists normal and rotten
throughout the game two of them can be
found near the Langdale Coliseum their
Helm reads bronze Helm decorated with
innumerable snakes worn by Gladiators
who were driven from the Coliseum the
wearer becomes a slightly easier Target
for foes the snake is viewed as a
traitor to the herd tree and the
audience delighted in seeing these
bronze Effigies beaten and battered the
Duelists showcase another example of the
past age of the coliseums when they were
much more of a lively spectacle as
compared to the decrepit loneliness we
find them as in game they hearken back
to a more exuberant time kind of like
how the coliseums of the real World
harken back to the lavish games and
combat of the Romans though the
reoccurring references to bronze are a
bit out of place with that comparison
considering that the Romans were more
Iron Age than Bronze Age either way they
speak to a past grandiosity that will
hopefully return in some way in the DLC
there is also the connection that the
Duelists representing the evil snakes
are ostracized persecuted people kind of
like the slave Gladiators of ancient
Rome in the same way as the attendees of
Rome's coliseums delighted in the
anguish of the slave Gladiators so too
did the attendees in the lands between
Delight in seeing the Duelists beaten
and battered due to their connection
with the snake the Duelists may have
been those aligned with the snake but
they also may have been retroactively
given such armor to wear to entice a
reaction out of the crowd in terms of
who or what the evil snake is that is
viewed as traitor to the Eritrea the
obvious candidate is the god devouring
serpent associated with Reichert there's
also more Christian mythology at play
here with the snake or serpent
representing Lucifer going against the
established religion of the erdry a
stand-in for God in this case one thing
that is complete speculation but would
be cool to have would be some PVE aspect
to the Arenas if we could fight Duelists
and orbeeze in a gauntlet maybe even do
co-op fighting of game enemies and
Invaders that would be a dope new thing
to have and if we do go back into the
past it would only make sense to have
all the old combatants of the coliseums
as our enemies in addition to some PV
peers this is basically just a wishlist
item but I think it would mesh well with
what we do have evidence for existing
and actual last point for the video we
can also find a gladiator weapon called
the star fist near the Langdale Coliseum
its description reads spherical iron
manifer covered in spikes which induce
blood loss used in brutal games of
pugilism or pugilism a manifer is
something that can guard your arm or
wrist while you're holding reins for
horses and pugilism or pugilism is
basically professional fighting this
doesn't have any big revolutionary
Insight but it does further the aura of
past professional fighting games taking
place in the coliseums and in even hints
to some degree of Chariots being part of
those games hopefully we will soon see
that aura return in full with that we
may be at the end end of what can be
substantially said about the DLC leak
and the lore around it if there was any
misinterpretation of the datamine info
on my part or if you have any lower
ideas of your own on the topic feel free
to mention so in the comments section
this news of the DLC is definitely
refreshing now we get to look forward to
when the announcement is made instead of
if the announcement will be made at all
there will surely be lots of lore to
cover with the DLC announcement and when
it obviously comes out since the main
aspect of the DLC will probably be
something completely separate from the
coliseums if fromsoft's pass releases
are anything to go off of we should get
a whole host of mainly PVE content that
should provide a lot of lore and New
Revelations to the game be sure to
subscribe and stick around if you're
looking forward to that lore and more
DLC news and Analysis here on the
channel and with that thanks for
watching until next time bye